bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur Public Sénat alors que le
gouvernement s'apprête à dévoiler ce
matin à l'occasion d'un comité
interministériel de nouvelles mesures de
simplification pour les entreprises et
les particulierers le Sénat a adopté
hier à l'unanimité le projet de loi de
simplification relations entre
l'administration et les citoyens premier
pas de la modernisation de l'État
envisagé par le gouvernement car il faut
dire que ce texte contient une petite
révolution juridique selon Matignon le
silence de l'administration vaudra
désormais acceptation et non plus rejet
comme c'était le cas auparavant alors
pour en savoir plus direction
l'hémicycle poursivre cette séance bonne
matinée à
tous l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion du projet de loi habilitant
le gouvernement à simplifier les
entre l'administration et les citoyens
dans la discussion générale la parole
est à Madame marielise Lebranchu
ministre de la réforme de l'État de la
décentralisation et de la fonction
publique merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le président de la commission
des lois Monsieur Jean-Pierre suer
monsieur le rapporteur HUG Portelli
Mesdames et Messieurs les sénatrices et
les sénateurs le texte que j'ai
l'honneur de vous présenter aujourd'hui
au nom du premier ministre exprime
l'engagement de gouvernement de
moderniser notre action publique dans un
monde qui change nous souhaitons mieux
répondre aux attentes des citoyens des
usagers pour conjuguer l'action publique
de l'État aux Collectiv jusqu'aux
collectivités locales dans cette
perspective nous vous proposons
d'engager trois réformes importantes
pour les Français trois réformes qui
permettront de simplifier et d'améliorer
les relations entre les Français et les
administrations toutes les
administrations faciliter la saisine de
l'administration par les usagers grâce à
l'utilisation du numérique codifier les
règles qui régissent ses relations entre
les citoyens et
l'administration changer en profondeur
la relation entre usagers citoyens et
administration nous vous proposons aussi
d'inverser le principe du refut àite qui
prévaut aujourd'hui au profit d'une
généralisation de l'accord de l'accord
tacite de l'administration
excusez-moi voilà trois outils qui
permettent de répondre mieux et plus
vite la mise en place d'un droit de
saisine des autorités administratives
par courrier électronique permettra de
sécuriser juridiquement les nombreux
échanges numériques qui existent déjà
via Internet y compris en dehors des
téléprocédures dédiées et permettra
aussi de donner àees échanges une valeur
de nature comparable au courrier papier
évidemment nous mettrons des gardes fous
contre les demandes abusives et le
faible nombre de problèmes constatés
dans les pays européens ayant déclenché
cette évolution aujourd'hui nous rassure
ce nou ce nouveau droit pardon viendra
compléter les efforts qui que font la
plupart des administrations en mettant à
la disposition des usagers des
téléprocédures qui fonctionnent très
bien à l'instar de celle qui a permis à
13,5 millions de Français de en ligne le
revenu cette année soit 6 % de plus que
l'an
dernier je tiens à souligner également
que c'est un levier d'amélioration des
conditions de travail des agents pour
qui les demandes abusives sont moins
délicates à gérer par mail qu'au
téléphone ou plus dur encore au guichet
nous vous proposons d'autoriser dans
certains domaines la communication des
avis donnés par une autorité au cours de
l'instruction d'un dossier pour
permettre aux usagers d'améliorer leur
projets et anticiper une décision
défavorable il s'agit pour nous de
renforcer la transparence et
l'élaboration de la décision
administrative et de limiter les risques
contentieux enfin et surtout que chacun
à sa place puisse gagner du temps dans
son article 2 ce projet de loi prévoit
la création par ordonnance d'un code
relatif aux relations entre les
administrations et les usagers nous
avons décidé de reprendre à notre compte
ce projet de code de l'administration
lors du prier comité interministériel de
la modernisation de l'action publique le
18 décembre 2012 tout en tirant les
leçons de la précédente tentative d'une
circulaire datée du 30 mai
1996 qui suite à une mauvaise définition
du projet avait été abandonnée en
janvier 2006 c'est pourquoi nous
proposons un code qui soit lisible pour
les usagers et qui soit centré sur la
seule question de sa relation avec les
administrations mesames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs la complexité du
monde appelle des procédures pour
protéger les citoyens et leurs droits
fondamentaux c'est certain elles sont
l'apanage d'un état de droit néanmoins
quand elles deviennent illisible et à ce
point complexe quand elle freineent
abusivement l'activité économique et les
projets des Français alors oui nous
avons le devoir de rationaliser ses
règles et de simplifier ses procédures
le président de la République a fait de
la simplification des normes et des
démarches administratives un combat qui
nous engage tous pour la compétitivité
de notre pays et le bien-être de nos
concitoyens le gouvernement sollicite
votre habilitation pour ces réformes
structurelles avec le Premier ministre
nous avons souhaité insérer à cet
ensemble de réformes que je vous
présente aujourd'hui les autorisations
tacites c'est ainsi que l'amendement
numéro 3 du gouvernement lance la mise
en chantier de la mesure annoncée par le
président de la République sur l'effet
du silence de
l'administration demain le silence de
l'administration sur une demande vaudra
en principe
acceptation cette révolution
administrative révolution juridique va
faciliter les projets de développement
public ou privés et améliorer la
réactivité des services administrativs
en charge de veiller au respect des
procédures légales aujourd'hui le
principe général considère qu'en
l'absence de réponse de l'administration
dans un délai de 2 mois son silence vaut
rejet de la demande c'est cela que le
gouvernement entend changer sachez qu'il
existe d'ors et déjà plus de 400
procédures dérogatoires soumises à un
régime d'approbation tacite en vertu de
l'article 22 de la Loi 2321 de 12 avril
2000 relative aux droits des citoyens
dans leur relation avec les
administrations mais malgré leur nombre
elle demur toutefois ell demeurent
toutefois largement minoritaire dans le
quotidien des Français aussi le
gouvernement propose de faire de la
règle qui prévaut déjà pour la plupart
des permis de construire des
autorisations de défrichement ou de
recours au chômage par
un principe de droit commun toutefois le
gouvernement prendra ses précautions
notamment dans le cas où sont en cause
les droits et libertés individuelles et
où l'application d'une règle différente
est imposée par une convention
internationale ou par le droit
communautaire seront aussi exclus les
demandes à caractère financier et les
procédures sensibles ou complexes
mettant en jeu des mettant en cause
pardon des enjeux de protection de
l'ordre public ou des risques
d'atteintre grave à la sécurité à la
santé ou à
l'environnement c'est ainsi que nous
proposons la constitution d'un groupe de
travail a les principales associations
d'élus et de parlementaires des deux
chambres pour identifier les procédures
locales concernées la commission
consultative d'évaluation des normes
dont la réforme est en cours sera
mobiliser elle aussi en ce sens pour
apporter aux collectivités toutes les
garanties de transparence nécessaires à
un tel exercice monsieur le Président
Monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
Messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs le
choc de simplification annoncé par le
président de la République le 28 mars
2013 est au cœur de l'amélioration de la
compétitivité hors coût de notre pays
comme l'ensemble de la démarche de
modernisation de l'action publique nous
avons besoin d'une action publique forte
au service du quotidien et de l'avenir
des Français sur tous les territoires
elle sera d'autant plus forte et
d'autant plus efficace Carelle sera
simple et
coordonné la force de notre pays c'est
d'avir su et de savoir s'adapter la
force de nos services public c'est aussi
de s'adapter sans cesse par cette
habilitation générale nous proposons au
pays des réformes structurelles majeures
qui auront des conséquences réelles sur
la vie quotidienne des entrepreneurs et
de tous les Français voilà l'ambition du
gouvernement je vous remercie de votre
attention merci Madame la
Ministre la parole est à Monsieur h
Portelli rapporteur de la commission des
lois monsieur le Président Madame le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois mes chers
collègues le projet de loi
d'habilitation qui vous est présenté
aujourd'hui s'inscrit dans un mouvement
législatif qui n'est pas spécifique à la
France et qui a débuté il y a maintenant
un peu plus de 40 ans
et ce mouvement tend à mettre le service
public au service du public en changeant
radicalement les relations entre les
administrations qu'ell soi nationale ou
locale direct ou délégué et les usagers
il concerne aussi bien les étâ de droit
écrit que ceux de common law et l'Union
européenne comme le Conseil de l'Europe
ont accompagné et favorisé ce
processus l'acte de naissance de ce
mouvement c'est la loi créant le
médiateur de la République en janvier
1973 et elle a été suivie par d'autres
la fameuse loi qui a créé la CAD
relative à l'accès au documents
administratifs en
1978 puis celle qui
a été relative à la motivation des actes
administratif en 1979 et surtout la loi
du 12 avril 2000 relative au droits des
citoyens dans leur relation avec
l'administration toutes ces lois vont
dans le même sens simplifi et rendre
plus transparentes les procédures
administratives et leur trait essentiels
sont d'abord le contrôle par l'usager du
service public des décisions qui sont
prises à son égard qu'il s'agisse de
l'accès au documents
administratifs de la motivation de ces
actes de leur
opposabilité d'autre part la
compréhension de ces actes qui doivent
être à la portée du public le plus large
et le moins formé aux subtilités du
droit
administratif troisièmement la
possibilité d'utiliser
les procédures les plus modernes et les
moins contraignantes pour dialoguer avec
les
administrations 4è de pouvoir accéder à
tous les niveaux et à tous les types
d'administration et donc cet ensemble
d'objectif est loin d'être arrivé à son
terme est lo d'être arrivé à son terme
pourquoi parce en permanence à des
barrages le principalentant la routine
administrative mais le aussi c'est
l'absence de volonté politique constante
des gouvernements successifs
pour avancer de façon non chaotique dans
cette direction alors les deux outils
traditionnels de cette de ce mouvement
législatif et réglementaire d'ailleurs
sont la codification et les
ordonnances les lois de simplification
qui ont été nombreuses au cours de la
dernière décennie qu'elles soit
d'origine parlementaire ou
gouvernemental ont donc eu largement
recours à cette
procédure après avoir été relancé dans
la deuxè moitié desannées
1990 la codification s'est ensuite
essoufflée et elle est appelée à un
nouveau départ avec la circulaire du
Premier ministre du 27 mars 2013
elle avance lentement non pas du fait de
la commission supérieure de codification
qui fait un très bon travail et qui a
donc d'ailleurs rédigé quelques codes
qui ne demande qu'à être mise en uvre
mais du fait de l'attitude des
gouvernements successifs qui ces travaux
de la commission de codification en
Dérance au risque de les voir devenir
obsolèes et donc adopter ces codes une
fois qu'ils ont été élaborés devient une
urgence
absolue la codification des différents
dispositions d'ordre législatif ou
réglementaire relative aux relations
entre les administrations et leurs
usagers est un des objectifs du projet
de loi qui prévoit notamment
l'achèvement du code de
l'expropriationors en ce qui concerne ce
dernier les travaux de la commission de
codification sont très largement avancés
ils sont quasiment en clos il s'agit
essentiellement de se mettre à jour de
la jurisprudence du Conseil
constitutionnel et demande donc une mise
en à jour rapide par contre
l'élaboration d'un code des relations
entre les administrations et leurs
usagers est beaucoup plus complexe car
elle nécessite trois
précotion la première c'est de ne pas
remettre en cause les codes qui existent
et qui fonctionnent bien notamment le
code de justice administrative le code
de l'urbanisme ou le code de
l'environnement et donc la procédure qui
sera utilisée c'est celle des renvois
vers ces codes tels qu'ils sont la
deuxième précaution c'est de travailler
non pas à droit constant mais en
intégrant les objectifs de la loi
d'habilitation et enfin trè objectif
c'est peut-être le plus important c'est
d'élaborer un code destiné au public le
plus large et donc qui soit maniable et
compréhensible par les non spécialistes
du droit
administratif alors depuis
1999 la méthode utilisé pour la
codification vous le savez c'est celle
des ordonnances puisque sa dimension
technique le justifie mais le recours
aux ordonnance est freiné par
l'incapacité chronique des pouvoirs
publics traduisé des gouvernements
successifs à mettre en œuvre les
habilitation
législative celles-ci sont très souvent
dépourvu d' faits faute d'élabor des
ordonnances par les
gouvernements il a fallu réhabiliter dès
lors les gouvernements suivants et
d'ailleurs souvent sans le moindre
résultat et lorsque les textes sont
élaborés et qu'ils ne sont pas soumis à
ratification et bien ils deviennent vite
obsolè faute de s'être REM d'accord sur
un délai suffisamment long et sur un
champ suffisamment
large alors aujourd'hui le projet de loi
que nous avons un air de famille avec
les projets de loi d'habilitation
antérieure puisquen grande partie il
puise son contenu dans les lois
d'habilitation qui ont été
successivement voté par cette assemblée
et la l'Assemblée nationale depuis
2004 et donc il s'agit d'espérer que
cette fois-ci ce sera la bonne alors
quelles sont les grandes orientations de
ce texte il prévoit donc comme on l'a
rappelé de faciliter le dialogue entre
les administrations et les citoyens
en généralisant le recours aux nouvelles
technologies de
l'information l'adoption d'un code des
relations entre l'administration et le
public mais il porte également madame le
ministre vient de le rappeler en germe
une rénovation du processus de décision
de
l'administration d'abord un mot sur les
la simplification des relations entre
les administrations et les usagers ce
qu'on appelle dans le texte le
public d'abord en créant ce code des
relations entre les administrations et
le public
madame le ministre l'a rappelé cette
idée n'est pas nouvelle mais cette
fois-ci la démarche est différente car
elle est plus pragmatique
elle tire en effet les leçons de l'échec
de la précédente tentative d'élaboration
d'un code de
l'administration le code envisagé cette
fois-ci est beaucoup plus
modeste plus orienté vers le citoyen que
vers
l'administration il n'est plus question
d'une somme regroupant suce des
dispositions etantentré aux procédures
administratives non contentieuse
l'ensemble des dispositions relatives à
l'organisation l'administration y
compris les autorités administratives
indépendantes de toute façon pour ceux
qui ça'inttéresse ils peuvent se se
reporter au dalallos du du code de
l'administration qui avait déjà fait le
travail c'est pas une page de publicité
ch préciser pour les services de la
séance et donc l'objectif cette fois-ci
c'est d'aller vers un texte plus
instrumental destiné au public qui ne
regroupera que les dispositions
relatives au relation entre
l'administration et ses usagers dont il
ennoncera les grands principes tels que
l'obligation de motivation des décisions
individuelles défavorables ou le droit
d'accès au documents administratifs ces
grands principes pourraient faire
l'objet d'un titre préliminaire d'après
ce que nous a dit le rapporteur publ de
la commission il contiendrait également
les règles générales du régime des actes
administratifs
unilatéraux ce code sera donc
généraliste et supplétif le gouvernement
indiquant dans l'étude d'impact qu'il
n'avait pas voocation à attraire dans
son champ les dispositions qui sont déjà
codifiées alors l'un des problèmes
des des tentatives antérieur était
l'absence d'organe de pilotage cette
fois-ci donc le secrétariat général du
Gouvernement s'en charge et c'est lui
donc qui aura la tutelle de la
commission supérieure de
codification afin de recueillir bien
laave de tous ceux qui sont concernés
notamment les
praticiens le code se fera donc à droit
non constant et ça vous explique
pourquoi il est prévu des des délais
modulables de
d'habilitation qui permettront de
procéder donc par
étape deuxème caractéristique du texte
la consécration des nouvelles
technologie par l'instauration d'un
droit de l'usager à saisir
l'administration par la voie
électronique alors ce n'est pas nouveau
puisque c'est depuis 2005 que ce type de
démarche a été euh amorcé mais cette
fois-ci donc le gouvernement demande une
habilitation plus générale pour adapter
les les administrations et le public aux
évolutions technologiques le
gouvernement sera également habilité à
simplifier les démarches du public
auprès des administrations et
l'instruction des
demandes alors une fois abordé donc le
champ voyons maintenant ce qu'il en est
de la rénovation du processus de
décision le premier point c'est le
nouveau régime des décisions implicites
lorsque le texte initial du gouvernement
était arrivé ici il n'y figurait pas
nous avons donc demandé au gouvernement
d'intégrer ces dispositions dans le
texte de façon à éviter que la loi
d'habilitation devienne obsolè au bout
de 6 mois donc par une petite micro
navette entre le gouvernement le SG et
la commission donc nous avons pu
bénéficier d'un amendement qui est donc
l'article additionnel au projet de loi
d'habilitation qui intègre donc la
proposition du Président de la
République
de suivant laquelle donc le silence
d'administration à l'expiration d'un
certain délai ne vaudrait plus rejet
mais autorisation ce qui inversera donc
le principe énoncé à l'article 21 de la
loi du 12 avril
2000 sauf dans les cas où un régime de
décision implicite de rejet sera
institué le silence gardé pendant plus
de 2 mois par l'autorité administrative
sur une demande vaudrait décision
d'acceptation alors bien entendu madame
le ministre l'a rappelé tout à l'heure
il y a toute une série de cas dans
lesquels ce type de principe ne pourra
pas prévaloir et d'ailleurs le Conseil
constitutionnel l'avait rappelé dès 1995
dans une de ces décisions en matière
d'engagements internationaux d'ordre
public de protection des libertés ou de
sauvegarde des autres principes à valeur
constitutionnel et bien il ne pourrait
pas
euh ne pourrait pas être introduit un
tel principe
la loi de 2000 a ajouté et le
l'amendement du Gouvernement le reprend
que les décisions en matière financière
à l'exclusion de du domaine de la
sécurité sociale sont également visé
alors il est évident que cette inversion
du principe va entraîner un profond
changement de la culture administrative
de l'État et des collectivités
publiques aujourd'hui la logique qui
prévaut c'est la logique du contentieux
qui permet à l'administré de saisir le
juge en cas d'inercie l'administration
demain le risque de décision tacite
illégale agira comme un aiguillon de
l'administration bien entendu il faudra
veiller à ce que ne se mettent pas en
place des dispositifs de
contournement par exemple par
l'instauration de délis rallongés ou de
moyens de retarder le déclenchement des
délais de naissance des décisions
implicites de même il ne faudrait pas
que les dérogations aux principes
nouveaux conduisent par leur nombre à le
vider de toute
portée donc la commission des lois se
faisant a donné un avis favorable à ce
dispositif en constatant notamment que
le gouvernement s'accorde un délé de 2
ans pour le mettre en œuvre au niveau de
l'état de des collectivités
territoriales pardon 2 ans pour les
collectivités territoriales et un ans au
niveau de l'État ce qui lui permettra
donc après concertation de pouvoir faire
le relever de tous les cas dans lesquels
et bien ce principe Deva être mis de
côté autre aspect de la rénovation du
processus de décision la possibilité
d'accéder aux avis préalables et de
modifier en conséquence ça demande quand
on est donc usager lorsque celle-ci est
en cours d'instruction là encore c'est
une rupture avec la règle traditionnelle
de non communicabilité des documents
préparatoires une décision
administrative qui est posé par la loi
du 17 juillet
1978 l'article 1er va habiliter le
gouvernement à prendre les dispositions
législatives pour pour prévoir qu'en
principe sont communicaable au demandeur
les avis rendus sur sa demande avant que
la décision ne soit prise cette mesure
concernerait tous les avis dès lors
qu'il serait formalisé et émanerit d'une
autre instance que l'autorité
administrative institutrice du dossier
ne sera exclu de son champ que les avis
dont la communication porterait atteinte
à la protection d'un secret ou aux
contraintes inhérentes à l'instruction
des dossiers alors la commission des
lois vous le verrez donc a modifié ce
texte de façon à ce que les
avis donc négatif soi motivés de façon à
ce qu'il
puissent donc avoir des effets pour
l'usager qui les demande 3ème élément
nouveau le renforcement de la
participation du public à l'élaboration
des actes
administratifs et
donc l'idée c'est que sans reprendre les
dispositions qui sont relatives aux
enquêtes publiques qui figurent déjà
dans le code de l'environnement et de l'
apprpriation le code des relations entre
l'administration et le public puisse
fixer des règles générales en la matière
qui serait un Tron commun pour
l'ensemble des autres codes que ceux qui
sont
exclus 4è élément l'élargissement de la
faculté de recourir aux nouvelles
technologies pour délibérer ou rendre
des avis à distance
donc l'idée que propose le gouvernement
c'est de l'habilité à étendre cette
faculté à toutes les organes des autorit
autorités administrativ y compris les
autorités administratives
indépendantes ce qui permettrait
évidemment d'alléer les
formalités la commission des lois n'y
est pas défavorable à condition bien
entendu que l'on préserve chaque fois la
collégialité des délibérations des lit
d'autorités et je crois que le
gouvernement là-dessus nous a suivi
enfin dernier point la simplification
l'unification des règles relatives au
régime des actes
administratifs donc le gouvernement
prévoit
que le la nouvelle dispositif législatif
aurait pour but de simplifier et je cite
lorsque cela est possible d'unifier les
règles relatives au régime des actes
administratif alors nous avons regardé
ce qui est dans l'exposé des motif
l'exposé des motifs fait allusion au
retrait donc ça vous explique pourquoi
nous avons précpité qu'il s'agissait
bien du retrait des actes administratifs
mais après avoir dialogué avec le
gouvernement nous y avons rajouté
l'abrogation de façon à ce
que aucun des champs de cette
simplification ne soit oubliée alors un
mot pour parler de la refonte du code de
l'expropriation c'est une refonte qui
est en cours depuis 2004
elle est quasiment terminée mais d'après
ce que nous ont dit les nos audit les
gens que nous avons diitionné et donc je
pense que cette fois-ci nous pourrions
enfin voir ce fameux code de
l'expropriation pour code d'utilité
publique alors le travail de la
commission donc je vous l'ai déjà en
grande partie énoncer je voudrais dire
qu'il a surtout porté sur deux points la
premier point le premier point c'était
de clarifier la rédaction du projet de
loi notamment pour parler des
bénéficiaires du texte c'estàdire le
public alors le public n'est pas une
catégorie juridique très usitée en droit
administratif alors vous remarquerez si
vous lisez le le texte de la commission
qu'on a essayé de le faire sortir au
maximum du libél mais en même temps on n
pas voulu non plus contrar le
gouvernement donc on a utilisé le moins
souvent possible au mot public et on a
utilisé donc des circonlocutions qui
permettent d'arriver au même résultat
sans froisser les professeurs de droit
public je connais bien voilà donc ça
c'était pour le droit pour le le public
ensuite le deuxème personne la deuxème
question c'était celle des des autorités
administratives alors là aussi on a eu
un dialogue intéressant avec le
gouvernement parce que en fait le le
texte aussi était souvent très fluctuant
dire que d'un la l're d'un aliné à
l'autre c'était pas le même mot qui
était utilisé tantôt des organismes
tantôt des autorités tantôt des
administrations donc il fallait savoir
un petit peu ce qu'on voulait donc nous
sommes partis sur une démarche de
simplification à notre tour et donc nous
avons utilisé la terminologie qui est
utilisée dans la loi de 2000 mais il
nous a été expliqué très récemment qu'en
fait le gouvernement ne faisait pas
allusion à la loi de 2000 mais à la loi
sur la CADA et que donc il fallait faire
référence aux autorités administratives
teles que la cadealentend et donc dans
un esprit constructif la Commission
s'est ralliée à ce point de vue alors en
ce qui concerne les avis préalables je
vous ai déjà dit que donc nous
souhaitons que chaque fois que possible
donc premièrement et bien pour les avis
qui seront défavorables il sont motivés
et que deuxièmement les débats euh
lorsqu'il s'agira d'utiliser les
nouvelles technologies ces débats soient
en permanence
collégiaux voilà donc pour l'essentiel
monsieur le Président Madame le Ministre
ce qui ont été les travaux de la
commission qui sur ce texte donc a eu un
point de vue globalement
positif merci monsieur le
rapporteur dans la suite de la
discussion générale la parole est à
Monsieur Alain Richard pour le groupe
socialisteés madame la ministre mes
chers
collègues je je souhaite bien entendu me
me placer dans la suite du propos du
rapporteur avec lequel je suis tout à
fait
d'accord et je voudrais au nom de de mon
groupe me concentrer principalement sur
la composante codification donc le le
texte d'habilitation que vous nous
présentez madame la
ministre ce que je veux dire en
commençant c'est qu'évidemment cette
démarche et cohérente avec l'objectif de
simplification qui a été fixé par le
président de la République et qui répond
à une
attente très très profonde chez les
différents partenaires de la société
française et qui je je le soulligne euh
crée maintenant une situation de tension
voire de méfiance ou d'hostilité
vis-à-vis de la puissance publique du
fait de la perte de lisibilité de
beaucoup euh de règles inspirant ou
encadrant le travail de
l'État alors cette codification h
Portelli a très bien dit qu'elle se
fixait un objectif limité et pour ceux
qui ont eu à se frotter à cet exercice
on voit bien que l'un des sujets les
plus comment dire vertigineux c'est la
délimitation c'est la fixation des des
bordures extérieures du travail de
codification évidemment quand on part du
cœur des missions de l'État ça peut
aller très très loin donc le le choix
qui a été fait que le teur a très bien
décrit est indiscutablement le bon c'est
celui qui est cohérent avec la démarche
de simplification ce que je veux
simplement souligner par témoignage
personnel c'est que c'est un processus
intellectuellement très exigeant parce
que ça oblige à essayer de reconstituer
une
cohérence qui est celle du législateur
dans sa continuité à partir de texte
etpart souvent adopté sous l'empire de
circonstances et modifié ou ajusté par
de multiples
reprises donc c'est c'est un des travaux
les plus ardus et c'est celui un de ceux
aussi dans lesquels on voit le mieux
travailler ce que j'appelle la enfin ce
que nous appelons entre disons les les
familiers la fabrique de la loi et
madame la ministre c'est l'occasion de
rendre hommage parce qu'on a pas si
souvent l'occasion dans sur ces ban à
tous ceux qui constituent le le noyau
humain de la fabrication de la
législation en France et de la
réglementation autour bien entendu du
secrétariat général du gouvernement mais
je vais aussi souligner l'apport
extrêmement utile de beaucoup de
services ministériels qui
délègu un ou plusieurs agents de haute
qualité pour contribuer à ce travail de
préparation et je crois qu'il faut aussi
se dire et ça peut-être une indication
vous gardiez à l'esprit madame la
ministre que du fait des évolutions
historique des partages de départements
ministériels on peut se faire un petit
guide des niveaux de d'aptitude et des
niveaux de potentiel des différents
services juridiques des ministères avec
des
étoiles et quand vous avez affaire et
c'est vrai aussi bien du gouvernement
que du législateur à un ministère
vraiment démuni de ce point de vue
c'estàd qui n'a plus le matériau humain
le potentiel humain pour fabriquer ses
propres textes évidemment on se trouve
dans des situations préoccupantes mais
donc je je conclus ce ce rappel de de
l'extrême utilité et du très fort
dévouement de l'ensemble des agents
publics qui participe à la fabrication
de la loi en soulignant le rôle euh
également très d'autant plus constructif
euh que il s'agit en général de tâche en
surcroix des autres qui est exercé par
la Commission de
codification j'ai eu le l'agrément d'y
participer dès sa création il y a 35 ans
c'était une des conséquences de la loi
de 78 et et nous y tenions et j'ai eu
l'agrément aussi d'y participer à
différents épisodes et je crois qu'il
faut dire que c'est une référence le le
travail de révision qui est fait par le
Conseil d'État en fin de parcours
démontre à chaque fois que j'en ai été
témoin que le travail de codification a
été parfaitement bien mené et donc si
j'ai simplement un petit message à
adresser à la ministre c'est évidemment
au milieu des efforts de répartition de
la pénurie qu'il faut faire d'essayer de
préserver les moyens humains de cette de
cette fabrique de la
loi la mission de ce texte va être
évidemment l'unification de notre droit
à partir donc de composantes qui peuvent
être qui n'ont pas forcément atteint
complètement la cohérence et euh
l'expérience a montré que quand on fait
ce travail euh donc on a réussi déjà à H
recenser l'ensemble des textes qu'il
faut mettre en jeu on trouve des
différences historiques dont plus
personne ne retrouve la la justification
et je pense que notamment dans les
procédures d'examin des dossiers dans
les procédures de préparation de
décision qui s'applique en réalité dans
les différents départements ministériels
il y a encore des différences que ce
travail de codification va permettre me
semble-t-il soit d'expliquer soit euh
plus préférablement de de surmonter et
puis dans la matière particulière dont
nous parlons qui donc en réalité les
procédures administratives dans leur
contact avec le public dans
leur comment dire dans dans l'issue
qu'elles apportent à la société dans son
ensemble la jurisprudence administrative
a un rôle très important et donc
j'imagine que ça ne se fera pas sans
quelques rétiscence en tout cas c'est ce
que j'ai encore entendu il y a peu de
semaines au sein de la commission de
codification mais je crois je crois
qu'il faudra malgré tout surmonter
comment dire le petit sens particulier
de la propriété qui peuvent encore
exercer que peuvent encore éprouver
quelques membres du Conseil d'État pour
que nous transférions cette
jurisprudence dans des règles de droit
positif comme on a été capable de le
faire il y a 15 ans pour faire le code
de justice administrative et et Dieu
sait qu'il a rendu
service alors sur le périmètre et le
champ d'application HUG Portelli a dit
ce qu'il fallait dire simplement moi
d'expérience et et en mesurant quand
même la modestie qu'il faut garder dans
ces travaux je ne suis pas sûr qu'il
soit raisonnable de chercher à conclure
de façon formelle au moment de la loi
d'habilitation sur ce que sera le champ
d'application finale parce que il
résultera aussi du travail de
codification et de sa logique et puisque
après tout ça c'est aussi un progrès que
nous avons fait dans la pratique de de
l'article 38 de la Constitution euh on
est arrivé maintenant à un vrai système
de validation à postériori des
codifications par ordonnance et donc la
loi de ratification peut-être l'occasion
de compléter ou d'adapter des éléments
du champ d'application qui se sont
révélés pendant le travail de
codification à ce sujet d'ailleurs je je
souhaiterais là aussi du fait de des
épisodes auquels j'ai pu participer je
souhaiteris vous faire une suggestion
ASI que services qui travaill sur ce
projet madame le ministre je crois qu'il
est utile notamment lorsqu'on travaille
à droit non constant ce qui est
évidemment souhaitable en la matière
qu'il y ait au moins un rendez-vous
intermédiaire entre les codificateurs et
les commissions
parlementaires lorsque une commission
not nos commissions des lois à
l'Assemblée au Sénat voit revenir une
ordonnance qui se caractérise en général
par quelques dizaines voire plus
logiquement centaines d'articles qui est
un produit fini alors que la seule chose
dont av eu à débattre en début de
processus c'était une loi d'habilitation
qui présentait quand même un caractère
assez abstrait hein qui permettait pas
forcément d'entrevoir tous les sujets
sur lesquels des options allaient être
prises moi c'est une c'est un réflexe
qui m'est revenu justement lorsque nous
débattions à la Commission de
codification de ce projet là j'ai je me
suis permis de dire au aux collègues de
la Commission sur un sujet comme
celui-là on devrait aller voir revenir
voir les commission des lois à la moitié
du travail notamment lorsque le plan est
adopté et lorsque la la charte de
l'ensemble des textes qu'on va
incorporer est est défini il me semble
que ça
garantirait contre une petite méfiance
une petite vigilance un peu négative qui
s'exerce forcément dans le au sein du
Parlement quand on voit revenir le
projet totalement fini et qu'on se dit
est-ce que le pouvoir règlementaire qui
a préparé cette ordonnance a
complètement respecté ce qui étaaiit nos
objectifs au
départ un mot aussi sur cette notion de
public puisqueen effet elle est tout à
fait inhabituel
simplement si on se lance dans le débat
ce que ce que nous avons fait à la
Commission de codification donc je suis
heureux d'en rendre compte au au Sénat
pour regarder quelles pourraient être
les
alternatives les citoyens
euh enfin l'ensemble des alternatives
nous ont conduit finalement à penser que
le public malgré son abstraction et son
caractère peu défini était en tout cas
pour le titre du code la meilleure
réponse et notamment moi ce qui m'a
convaincu c'est que ça va beaucoup
concerner les entreprises et pas
seulement les particuliers et donc il il
faut je crois comme on l'a fait
d'ailleurs pour certains des textes
passés que que le rapporteur a justement
rapporté je crois qu'il vaut mieux
adopter la définition la plus la plus
large même si elle est imprécise de des
destinataires de de ce
code à propos de de de l'aboutissement
peut-on l'espérer en tout cas du code de
l'expropriation qui sera une bonne
nouvelle quand nous le verrons vraiment
et j'espère que c'est c'est proche
maintenant il y a quelques autres
urgences je pense au code électoral qui
est dans un état déplorable et dont le
travail si je ne me trompe est assez
bien
avancé et puis là j'ai met un message de
l'audace sera pererçu par quelques
personnes dans
l'assistance le contraire de l'urgence
c'est l'état du code général des
impôts il est dans un tel état
maintenant que plus personne n'ose
envisager sa
recodification
mais à part vraiment les fiscalistes
endurcis et encore il faut quelques
années justement pour y parvenir c'est
un un document qui est quand même vital
pour la société pour l'économie
française qui n'est absolument plus
maniable donc malgré la difficulté de de
l'exercice je me permets de vous
suggérer Madame le Ministre d'insister
auprès de vos collègues de Bercy et
collègues et voisins d'ailleurs pour que
ce travail soit sérieusement entrepris
parce que ce n'est plus
possible autre petit message personnel
nous avons manqué de peu l'adoption à
cette session extraordinaire de la
proposition de loi du président suur et
de Madame Gouro la présidente de la
délégation
pour la révision du système d'évaluation
des normes alors que je crois en tout
cas les services du Premier ministre
nous ont confirmé que le travail auquel
nous avions abouti leur convenait
parfaitement bon c'est le résultat
indésirable de la surcharge des deux
commissions des lois et notamment de
celle de nos collègues de l'Assemblée
donc je je suis je n'ai pas de doute
madame la ministre que vous serez de
notre avis pour insister auprès des des
collègues et amis de l'Assemblée pour
que nous terminions sur ce texte et que
nous ayons un vrai outil partenarial
entre le monde des élus locaux et
l'administration centrale et les
services du Premier ministre pour mieux
mieux contrôler mieux maîtriser la
production de normative
nouvelle je termine monsieur le
Président en saluant le travail qui a
déjà été fait pour la préparation de C
cette loi d'habilitation et en saluant
l'ambiance de convergence entre le
gouvernement et l'ensemble des groupes
de l'assemblée qui est je crois un
augure de réussite de
l'entreprise merci chers
collègu la parole est à Monsieur
Christian Favier pour le groupe
CRC
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers
collègues ce projet de loi donc comprend
trois articles qui autorise le
gouvernement à légiféré par voie
d'ordonnance dans différents domaines
avant de parler du contenu de ces
articles je voudrais dire un mot sur la
forme vous n'ignorez pas que nous sommes
pour notre part opposés à la pratique
des ordonnances l'article 38 de la
Constitution autorise notamment le
gouvernement à demander au Parlement
l'autorisation de prendre par ordonnance
et pour une durée limitée des mesures
qui sont du domaine de la loi ce faisant
les ordonnances sont finalement un moyen
de contourner les règles de démocratie
normal notamment celle de l'élaboration
et de l'adoption de la loi par le
Parlement bien qu'encadré donc par la
loi ces ordonnances nen constitu pas
moins donc un empiettement du pouvoir
exécutif sur le pouvoir lég
et donc d'une certaine manière une forme
d'atteinte au principe de séparation des
pouvoirs le Parlement n'a alors plus
qu'un pouvoir de validation
d'invalidation sans possibilité
d'intervenir sur le contenu le
gouvernement intervient donc à la place
du Parlement et l'article 38 ne délimite
le domaine de compétence que de manière
bien dire laconique mentionnant
simplement je cite l'exécution de son
programme c'estàdire sans interdire à
priori aucun domaine
si le Conseil constitutionnel effectue
un contrôle à postériorie nous pouvons
considérer que ce dernier évidemment
n'est pas suffisant une nouvelle fois
donc nous mettons en garde contre la
banalisation de ces pratiques qui
concernent des domaines il faut bien le
voir donc de plus en plus large en
l'occurrence donc ce projet de loi
autorise le gouvernement à légiférer par
voie d'ordonnance dans plusieurs
domaines distincts qui en réalité sont
plus larges que la seule simplification
des relations entre l'administration et
le citoyen quiénonce le titre du projet
de loi l'article 1 habilite le
gouvernement afin de créer un droit des
usagers à saisir les autorités
administratives par voie électronique
d'autoriser les délibérations à distance
des services administratifs à
l'exclusion des instances délibératives
de collectivité local et enfin autorise
le gouvernement à préciser que les avis
préalables doivent être communiqués
avant l'intervention de
l'administration cet article a donc bien
pour objectif la mise en œuvre d'une
simplification des relations
administration citoyen et
l'établissement donc d'une plus grande
transparence dans ces relations en
adaptant donc ces dernières aux
technologies numériques et aux
évolutions des usages donc qui en
découlent sur le fond évidemment nous ne
voyons aucun obstacle bien au contraire
à cela il paraît pertinent de créer une
obligation de mettre en place davantage
de téléprocédures et de services
numérique à destination des citoyens
corollaire du droit des usagers à saisir
les autorités administ par voie
électronique même si nous devons j'en
ferai une remarque sur ce point veiller
peut-être à ce que ce développement des
des procédures donc numérique ne
conduisent pas effectivement à créer
parfois une fracture entre avec une
partie de nos concitoyens qui reste et
qui demeure on le sait encore éloigné
parfois de ces pratiques et de ces
outils donc c'est évidemment une
préoccupation tout comme il nous
paraortant de mettre de permettre que
les avis préalables soient communiqués
avant l'intervention de la décision de
l'administration
cela permet en cas d'avis préalable
négatif par exemple une modification du
projet avant même la décision finale et
garantissant donc ainsi plus de
transparence dans les décisions mais
aussi plus de rapidité dans l'exécution
du projet qui pourra alors être réévalué
avant la décision finale dans le même
esprit nous considérons que la
proposition du gouvernement donc par
amendement de considérer que faute de
réponse de l'administration donc dans
les de mois une demande euh à certaines
demandes cette demande aura valeur donc
d'un accord tacite et ça constitue
effectivement un vrai progrès je pense
pour les usagers là aussi ça pose quand
même en même temps une question qui est
celle des moyens évidemment des services
publics de pouvoir aussi instruire dans
ces
délais dans des conditions
satisfaisantes évidemment pour pouvoir
donc veiller à ce que toutes les
précautions a été pris évidemment en la
matière pour que cette acceptation ne
soit pas Simp simplement le résultat
effectivement d'un embouteillage des
demandes et de fait donc une
satisfaction qui serait donnée sur ce
plan mais que ça soit bien aussi le
résultat quand même d'un examen attentif
des demandes l'article 2 quant à lui
fait suite au déclaration du comité
interministériel pour la modernisation
de l'action publique qui a affirmé la
nécessité de créer un code donc de
relation entre l'administration les
citoyens comprenant les grands principes
comme l'obligation de motivation des
décisions individuelles défavorables ou
l'accès au documents administratifs
ainsi cet article donc permet au
gouvernement de procéder par ordonnance
à l'adoption de la partie législative
d'un nouveau code relatif aux relations
entre les administrations et le public
procédure administrativ non
contentieuses et régime des actes pris
par les administrations en vigueur il
précise également que le gouvernement
pourra modifier des règles de procédure
dans un but de simplification des
relations et de développement des usages
numériques ainsi
donc dition de ce code ne s'effectuera
pas pleinement à droit constant et
laissera donc une marge de liberté au
gouvernement qu' nous paraît difficile
évidemment de valider à priori sans
connaître exactement le champ donc de
cette dernière le rapporteur a certes
circonscrit le champ de ses
habilitations ce dont nous félicitons
sans pour autant créer les conditions
donc d'une codification à droit constant
et donc les garantie d'une sécurité
juridique en outre la durée
d'habilitation de 24 mois prévu par
cette article est particulièrement
longue enfin l'article 3 concerne lui le
code d'expropriation pour Cuse utilité
publique il autorise le gouvernement à
agir par ordonnance pour simplifier le
plan du code donner les compétences en
appel à la juridiction de droit commun
et y inclure la jurisprudence du Conseil
constitutionnel si cet article ne nous
pose pas non plus de problème
particulier sur le fond cet article
relatif au logement à nos yeux en tout
cas n'en reste pas moins une forme de
cavalier législatif il est étonnant
qu' qu'il figure effectivement dans ce
projet de loi et n'est pas été inclus
soit dans la loi d'ordonnance sur
l'urbanisme le logement qui a été adopté
le 29 mai et publié d'ailleurs au
Journal Officiel le 2 juillet ou dans le
projet de loi du flot sur le logement
examiné en ce moment même à l'Assemblée
nationale compte tenu du fait que sur le
fond de ce projet de loi évidemment ces
articles n pose pas de problème majeurs
nous voterons donc pour ce texte malgré
je le répète donc notreos je dirais de
principe à la pratique des ordonnances
et malgré également les réserves que
nous avons exprimé sur le domaine la
durée de l'article 2 et la présence d'un
article sur le logement évidemment dans
ce projet de
loi merci chers
collègu la parole est à monsieurre pour
le groupe udi
UC
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers
collègues comme vous le savez madame la
ministre le bilan que notre groupe
dresse de la politique mené par Lionel
Jospin Premier ministre est parfois
sévère pour autant au-delà de toutes les
querelles qui peuvent persister je crois
qu'il existe aujourd'hui un vaste
consensus autour de ce que la doctrine
de droit public appelle les lois de 2000
et au cœur de celle-ci de la loi du 12
avril 2000 sur les droits et les
relations entre les citoyens et
l'administration il y a 13 ans cette loi
a permis de lever un certain nombre
d'incertitude quant à l'opacité parfois
fantasmée il faut le dire de l'action
administrative
elle a notamment permis d'inscrire dans
la loi le principe que le silence de
l'administration vos décisions de rejet
sauf dans des cas spécifiques énumérés
par une importante série de décret en
Conseil d'État je dois dire par rapport
à ce point que j'ai du mal à comprendre
pourquoi on va aujourd'hui inverser
cette règle qui me semble- il a pas si
mal fonctionné que cela cette démarche
pour autant reste inachevée à bien des
égards il s'agit aujourd'hui donc de
faire du service public si on peut dire
un service à destination du public il
s'agit en somme de faire du citoyen plus
qu'un simple administré et d'en faire un
acteur à part entière des relations
administratives l'amélioration des
relation entre l'administration et le
citoyen est une préoccupation majeure
pour les sénateurs quelques d'entre nous
ont la chance et quand je dis
quelquesuns c'est un grand nombre
d'entre nous ont la chance d'être à la
tête d'une collectivité territoriale et
donc d'une
administration qui reçoit chaque jour
des citoyens en tant qu'usagers de
l'administration et auprès desquels
remonte un certain nombre de problèmes
depuis une quinzaine d'années nous avons
pu voir évoluer la rapidité du
traitement des demandes que ce soit pour
une carte d'identité pour un passeport
pour un permis et cetera mais
contraintte demeure aujourd'hui les
relations entre les citoyens et
l'administration locale reflètent
souvent une impatience et je dirais on
peut le dire je crois des
exigences le
problème et et me semble--il celui-ci
derrière les concepts juridiques il y a
d'abord des hommes et des femmes aussi
il n'est pas tout à fait anodin de
modifier les règles relatives aux
modalités des délai de retrait ou
d'abrogation des actes istratif un grand
pas en avant avait été fait en 2001 avec
une décision Ternon du Conseil d'État le
citoyen disposé même après clôture du
délai de recours en excès de pouvoir de
2 mois pour solliciter de
l'administration le retrait d'un acte
individuel créateur de droit
malheureusement derrière ce débat de
juriste le citoyen maîtrise mal les
subtiles différences entre un acte
explicitement ou implicitement créateur
de droit de la même manière tous ne Mani
pas avec autant d'aisance que les
membres de la juridiction administrative
la différence entre le retrait et
l'abrogation d'un acte j'avoue que
moi-même même après les étude que j'ai
fait il y a maintenant longtemps j'ai
parfois des doutes beaucoup a été fait
pour que la langue juridique de
l'administration soit plus accessible au
plus grand nombre mais l'essentiel du
travail reste encore devant nous tant
cette opacité reste pourrait-on dire
l'un des attributs sinon l'un des
éléments de puissance de
l'administration aussi je ne peut
qu'accueillir favorablement l'initiative
prise par le gouvernement de créer un
code spécifique aux relations entre les
citoyens et l'administration cette
codification devrait être une
opportunité pour clarifier les
dispositions existantes et notamment la
postérité de la jurisprudence tern que
ce soit en matière de retrait ou
d'abrogation ce code sera également
l'occasion de permettre aux relations
entre l'administration et les citoyens
de prendre la voix de la de la
matérialisation que l'informatique nous
permet ou devrait nous permettre la
démultiplication des outils numériques
doit être mise au service de l'action
administrative et je crois que le débat
d'aujourd'hui est l'occasion de dire que
on peut faire évoluer de multiples
manières les relations entre
l'administration et l'usager si on ne
met pas l'accent sur le développement du
numérique il y aura encore un certain
nombre de malentendus pendant un nombre
certains d'années la rénovation des
processus décisionnels de
l'administration est également une
avancée louable plus qu'une rénovation
c'est une révolution administrative qui
est en préparation c'est la fin du
principe de non communicabilité des des
documents préparatoires et le début d'un
dialogue voire d'une coproduction mais
ça c'est peut-être un peu osé de la
décision entre le citoyen et
l'administration enfin l'annonce récente
faite par le gouvernement d'inverser le
sens du silence de l'administration pour
en faire une décision positive par
principe est un gage de confiance pour
nos concitoyens peut-être le droit
administratif ne sera-t-il plus
caractérisé par son seul caractère
exorbitant du droit commun ou du moins
dérogatoire du droit privé mais comme un
droit de dialogue de Concorde et de
consentement des citoyens administrés
pour autant madame la ministre
permettez-moi une remarque un projet de
loi d'habilitation du gouvernement à
prendre des mesures par par voie
d'ordonnance et toujours comme une
promesse on s'engage sur un programme
bien souvent très ambitieux et force est
de constater que parfois les mesures
prises sont en deess des espérances
nourries les dispositions de la nouvelle
rédaction de l'article 38 de la
Constitution ne nous permettent pas de
contrôler directement le texte des
ordonnances mais seulement de nous
prononcer sur leur ratification aussi
peut-il être considéré comme regrettable
que les dispositions que vous souhaitez
introduire dans notre droit ne fasse pas
l'objet d'un véritable projet de loi qui
aurait permis un examen en séance
publique plus serré disons cependant
madame la ministre nous sommes
évidemment prêts à vous laisser le
bénéfice du doute quant à vos projets
d'ordonnance mais sachez que nous serons
vigilants qu au contenu effectif de ce
que vous mettrez en œuvre je vous
remercie merci chers
collègues la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Claude requier pour le groupe
RDSE
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues un constat s'impose
les Français expriment une profonde
défiance à l'égard de leur
administration comme le révèle le
dernier rapport des du Défenseur des
droits il met en lumière un paradoxe qui
est de notre devoir de corriger à savoir
des droits sont proclamés par le
législateur et dans le même temps nous
construisons des labyrinthes pour
permettre à chacun d'y accéder tels sont
les termes employés par nos concitoyens
pour décrire le paysage administratif
français et cette situation est est
d'autant plus préoccupante que je cite
le rapport plus l'individu est précaire
plus les droits ne lui soit accessible
qu'au terme d'un
dédal la simplification des procédures
administratives est indispensable si
l'on veut renforcer l'efficacité de
l'action de l'administration et dans les
même temps la confiance des citoyens
envers leurs
fonctionnaires l'article 15 de la
Déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyens ne prévoit-il pas que la
société a le droit de demander comptes à
tout agent public de son administration
c'est donc une évidence mais l'État doit
être exemplaire l'État et donc ses
agents
administratifs tous les organismes
chargés d'une mission de service public
doivent être impliqués dans la recherche
d'une modernisation de leur action car
elle constitue un levier puissant de
réduction structurelle des dépenses
publiques elle doit viser à rationaliser
les dépasses de fonctionnement pouvant
être réduire à de consacrer ses dépenses
à l'investissement et à l'intervention
publique à la différence de la RGPP les
agents doivent être associés à ce
changement tout profond de culture
cependant cet idéal ne peut être atteint
dans un environnement qui ne cesse de
contribuer on doit le dire à la
prolifération et à la complexification
des normes ce qui suppose de revisiter
l'organisation territoriale de l'État
avec une meilleure répartition des rôles
comme le Pr précise la Cour des comptes
dans un rapport récemment publié dans le
même temps l'excès de norm pèse sur les
citoyens sur les entreprises sur les
agents eux-mêmes pour ces derniers
l'accueil devient particulièrement
difficile et il peut s'avérer source de
tension le temps des procédures
correspond à des jours de congés pris
par les salariés pour accomplir leur
démarche parfois sans succès il
correspond à tout ce temps que les
entreprises peuvent consacrer à leur
activité pour la consolider et la S
grandir en ce qui concerne
l'entreprises le rapport du député
Mandon extime qu'il est possible de
réduire de 80 % les coûts liés à la
complixité et à la lenteur des
procédures ce sont des coûts qui
seraient beaucoup plus profitables à
l'investissement et à l'emploi il y a
donc là un jugement substantiel
d'économie permettant de relancer la
compétitivité de notre pays en n en
outre la norme doit être stable et
lisible pour garantir une véritable
source sécurité juridique et limiter les
recours devant les tribunaux que l'on
peinene à désengorgé enfin pour être
respecté la norme doit être comprise par
tous faire simple en quelque chose en
quelque sorte et à la matière des
progrès rest à faire aux multiples
tentatives destinées à répondre à toutes
les situations particulières la raison
d'être de la norme est souvent oubliée
aux multiples tentatives de
simplification la ration ne fait souvent
que pourouver son Inergie ainsi pour
reprendre une citation de Jean de La
Fontaine le trop d'attention que l'on a
pour le danger fait plus souvent qu'on y
tombe alors le présent projet de loi
évitera cet écueil le droit
estimplifiable cette question est
récurrente et le choc de compétitivité
juridique prené par le rapport Lambert
Boulard contre l'inflation normative ne
serait encore attendre la volonté du
gouvernement semble bien réel puisqu'il
a procédé à la suppression récente du
cent de commission consultative dont le
rôle était limité nous le savons il est
nécessaire de partir de l'usager pour
revisiter les procédures administratives
c'est l'approche retenue par la DGME
c'est la logique que doit inspirer la
rédaction du nouveau Code
d'administration tant attendu en effet
si vo le jour grâce à cette nouvelle
habilitation qui permettra de rassembler
de mettre à disposition de manière clair
les règles procédurales non
contentieuses auprès des usagers et des
entreprises la possibilité de
régulariser une demande en cours
d'instruction grâce à la communicabilité
des avis préalables à la décision
définitive constitue également une
avancée cette réforme doit être
l'occasion d'étendre cette possibilité à
l'ensemble des démarches administratives
avec la consécration du droit de saisir
l'administration par la voie
électronique si la présence de l' US
ager peut se justifier une fois son son
identité vérifiée bien sûr le restant
des pièces justificatives à fournir doit
pouvoir lui être communiqué par voie
électronique ou encore par
correspondance à cet égard l'utilisation
accrue du numérique est un outil
indispensable de la modernisation de
l'action publique ce qui requiert un
investissement en logiciel et en
formation ainsi que de nouvelles rles
nouvelles règles procédurales toutefois
il faudra veiller à ce que la à réduire
la facture numérique pour que l'ensemble
de la population puisse accéder à ces
services dans tout le territoire de la
République le silence de
l'administration vaudra acceptation et
non plus rejet a fermé le président de
la République lors de sa conférence de
presse du 16 mai dernier une telle
perspective aussi aussi séduisante
soit-elle n'est pas s'en poser quelques
questions ainsi le gouvernement nous
propose par la voix de d' amendement et
don sans étude d'impact d'adopter une
telle logique qui induirait un
changement radical pour ne pas dire
davantage dans notre manière de
concevoir le droit et qui implique une
étude approfondie de l'ensemble des
procédures qui pourrait être concerné il
faut bien reconnaître que le moyen
utilisé est d'autant plus contestable
que le gouvernement déposé le projet de
loi il y a juste un mois au Sénat et que
cette petite révolution selon les termes
employés par
Madame le Ministre Valo belcassem selon
la révolution administrative vot selon
vos terme madame la ministre avait été
annoncé en mai le motif d'une telle
disposition légitime l'accélétion des
procédures bien sûr nous y sommes
favorables sur le fond
toutefois disposeon de moyens humains et
permettant aux services d'étudier les
demandes d'un délai raisonnable pensons
en particulier dans les mairies au
certificat d'urbanisme et au documents
de droit du sol une fois ces moyens mis
en place les services doivent pouvoir
être responsabilisés car leur inaction
produira des effets de droit la réponse
doit être claire pour le demandeur et ne
doit pas dépendre l'inertie ou la
rapidité d'un service administratif
particulier la cohérence des décision
doit être assurée sur tous les
territoires de la République pour tous
les citoyens français il convient de
s'interroger avant tout sur les raisons
qui entraînent aujourd'hui de tel délais
destruction les délais prévus sont-ils
raisonnables toutes les étapes de la
procédure sont-elles
indispensables et les agents traitant
certaines demande sont-ils en nombre
suffisant et et suffisamment motivés il
ne faudrait pas chers collègues que la
précipitation aboutisse à un résultat
contraire au bout de poursuivi qui est
juste celui d'assurer à nos concitoyens
une bonne et juste administration elle
ne doit pas aboutir à l'adoption
ultérieure de mesures législatives
destinées à apporter des exceptions à ce
nouveau principe par ailleurs le
gouvernement avait également annoncé à
la suite du CMAP du 2 avril dernier
qu'il allait favoriser une
interprétation
facilitatrice du droit existant une
attention particulière accorder si on
souhaite que le principe d'égalité
devant la loi s'applique à tous les
citoyens les Senateurs du groupe RDSE il
sont très attachés en début de ces
remarques madame la ministre nous
approuvons ce projet de loi don nous
partageons la finalité améliorer la
qualité des services public renforcer la
qualité du dialogue entre fonctionnaires
citoyens et permettre ainsi de restaurer
la cette confiance nécessaire entre les
premiers et les seconds il n'y a pas de
véritable démocratie sans une
administration compétente au service de
l'État républicain et de
citoyens merci chers
collègues la parole est à Madame Mélanie
pietre pour le groupe
écologique
commencer par
ça monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues les habitants de notre
beau pays ont eu de nombreux noms cel
Gaulois galloromain mérovingien sujet
puis
administré pourtant les Français
aujourd'hui se rêvent citoyens
citoyennees entendu d'une administration
perçue comme
lointaine je ne dirais pas bien sûr que
la que l'administration est sans
problème je la Cour des comptes vient de
nous le rappeler donc la simplification
des formalité administrative est
évidemment une nécessité les méandres de
l'accès à des informations de la
préparation de dossierers de leur dépôts
des recours sont des freins objectifs au
droit des citoyens citoyens
par ailleurs la large diffusion de
l'accès à Internet est une chance à
saisir mais internet ne peut pas tout
car la vie sociétale c'est d'abord des
liens entre entre individus et non avec
une machine la décision de simplifier
les relations avec l'administration et
les citoyens ne peut donc qu'être
encouragé et l'idée de la codifier est
bienvenue reste que ce texte s'il a pour
but écrit de renforcer le dialogue entre
l'administration et les citoyens
ne renforce pas le dialogue entre le
gouvernement et les parlementaires et
c'est là son plus gros défaut
premièrement ce projet de loi présente
les parlementaires comme des êtres
frustres incapables de comprendre la
complexité de l'administration voire des
thèmes techniques qui seront abordés
dans les ordonnances bref restons entre
fonctionnaires pour arranger nos
rapports avec les citoyens sans laisser
à leurs représentants le droit c'est
bien le cas de le dire d'y mettre leur
grain celle le gouvernement pensent-t-il
que les parlementaires les associations
les citoyens qui les épaulent ne sont
pas capables d'effectuer des analyses
techniques et que seul les
fonctionnaires du ministère le sont je
pense bien que non mais je pense que
j'ai vraiment très mauvais esprit le
second motif est que les ordonnances
protégeraient d'un d'un encombrement
excessif le travail
parlementaire effectivement en matière
d'encombrement excessif ou non le
gouvernement est un expert nous avons
des a eu tout notre sous de projet de
loi avec peu de temps pour préparer et
réfléchir nous avons su y faire face
mais combien de nos réunions ont été
inutiles puisque les textes n'avaient
pas été discutés en amont et
l'amendement surprise du gouvernement
qui nous arrivé ce matin en est
l'exemple flagrant il s'agit d'un
amendement qui modifie la Loi dans la
loi même qui autorise le gouvernement à
la codifieré long de de pages il fait
droit au dicton qui ne dit mot cons sent
mais cette am amendement complexe
modifiant la loi et non la modifiant
mérite plus qu'une simple lecture en
séance le jour même de sa discussion en
hémicycle c'est pourquoi rien que pour
la forme évoquée ici les écologistes ne
pourront le voter pour le fond je
reprendrai la parole plus
tard ainsi vouloir nous faire croire que
c'est pour notre bien que le
gouvernement passe par-dessus nos votes
ne laisse rien pressager de bon
concernant la ratification des ces
ordonances car si nous avons pas le si
nous n'avons pas le temps aujourd'hui de
discuter ces mesures aurons donc plus le
temps pour analyser les dites mesures
une fois revenu devant nous pour
approbation surtout que cette
codification n'est pas à droit constant
mais à droit
innovant faudra-t-il alors avoir une
confiance aveugle en les techniciens qui
les ont qui ont rédigé ces mesures
n'avons-nous rien appris des ratés
techniques à minima coûteux à maxima
en qui pose problème prenez par des
techniciens sans légitimité démocratique
qui serait apte à savoir mieux que nous
ce qui est bon pour tous le nucléaire en
particulier le surgénérateur dont nous
promettait la lune énergétique qui se
révèle un puiv financier sans fond et
présente des risques sanitaires et
économique infin les organismes
génétiquement modifiés qui devaient
nourrir la planète et apportent la
pauvreté aux agriculteurs pied et point
liés et qui aux États-Unis ont permis de
vérifier en moins de an l'adaptabilité
du vivant pued donné à la bruetabilité
du vivant l'informatisation de la
sécurité sociale par la carte Vitale
toujours pas au point coûteuse et
n'ayant pas atteint les buts recherchés
d'éridication de la d'éradication de la
faute de réduction des déficits et
présentant une violation manifeste du
secret professionnel le vote
électronique qui pose des problèmes de
sécurité et de véracité du vote sans
parvenir à l'économie et à diminuer les
abstentions qui étaent mis en avant lors
de ses premiers
déploiements de même que nous élus
n'avons pas su prendre la mesure des
attentes citoyennes quant à notre
transparence de patrimoine permettez-moi
madame la ministre de douter que votre
administration que notre administration
sache mieux que nous organiser sa propre
transparence mais encore une fois je
suis vraiment mauvaise
langue merci chers collègues et bien
nous passons la parole à Monsieur
jean-jacquesest pour le groupe
MP monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers collègu euh ben notre
administration elle était établi
solidement sur une organisation
hiérarchique et un pouvoir unilatéral
c'est pourquoi Monsieur le Rapporteur
euh assujéti usager enfin il y a tout un
tas de termes qui prouvaient assujéti
d'ailleurs c'est merveilleux c'est sujet
on est assujetti c'est extraordinaire le
public c'est mieux de ce point de vue
hein et il faut bien reconnaître que
l'autonomie croissante des collectivité
locale et l'évolution culturelle qui
anime nos concitoyens nous pousse
aujourd'hui à refaçonner le
fonctionnement de nos
institutions le droit et là se
complexifie au fil du temps et nous
devons toujours veiller à ce qu'il soit
accessible à nos concitoyens qui sont de
surcroix animés d'un souhait croissant
de participation et de contrôle on
discute tout maintenant c'est décision
du
maire l'objectif des textes qui vise à
améliorer la relation
entreadministration et nos concitoyens
doit veiller à allier transparence et
efficacité comme l'a rapporté comme l'a
rappelé le rapporteur ce travail n'est
pas nouveau alors avec la loi d'abord de
du 3 juin 73 institution Médiateur de la
République ça n'était pas passé
facilement c'était le sénateur tiot qui
était le grand qui soutenait cette chose
et c'était pas évident et bien sûr la
loi du 17 juillet 78 pour l'accès au
documents administratif celle de 79
relative à la motivation des actes
administratifs et bien entendu la loi du
12 avril 2000 relatif au droits des
citoyens dans leur relation avec
l'administration qui a donné un regain à
cette évolution le projet du
gouvernement s'inscrit donc dans la
droite ligne des dispositions de la loi
2000 qui engage l'adaptation graduelle
de l'administration face aux enjeux
sociétaux et
technologiques alors je rappellerai
quand même sous la précédente
législature avec plus ou moins de
bonheur ou plutôt un bonheur des
croissants il y a eu quatre lois de
simplification que personne n'a cité
peut-être parce que elles nous ont posé
quelques problèmes au Sénat il y a une
loi 2007 de 2009 de 2011 de 2012
d'ailleurs était plus de simplification
elle était de complexification
simplification et d'ailleurs c'est là où
je vous rappelle mes chers collègues que
on voulait nous faire passer le code de
l'expropriation et on a dit non non non
c'est pas mur il faut faire très
attention le projet de loiitant le
gouvernement relation entre
l'administration et les administrés doit
améliorer l'efficacité
souhaitée on peut toujours dire qu'on
est contre les
ordonnances mais il y a un moment où de
toute façon il faut bien procéder de
cette manière la différence c'est
maintenant qu'il y a une révision
constitutionnelle qui oblige à ratifier
explicitement toutes les ordonnances et
donc nous aurons à
voir le moment venu les textes qui
sortiront de des travaux du
gouvernement alors bien entendu la
modernisation des techniques employées
parextension de voie électronique profit
aux usagers du service public qui
utiliseront à juste titre les procédés
présentés à l'instar des avis préalables
qui seront destinés à l'élaboration
d'une communication intelligible entre
administration et
administré l'accessibilité la
multiplication d'innet adressé aux
administrations faciliteront leur tâches
et et donc l'article 1er précise que le
recours aux technologies permettra sens
administrative collégiale de délibérer à
distance je pense que c'est des progrès
qu'il faut utiliser nous l'avions fait
Madame le Ministre non pas
par pour même pour la justice je
rappelle ça avait été critiqué mais
comment faire pour les pour les
justiciables de Saint-Pierre et Milon de
réunir un tribunal entier et ben ça veut
dire qu'on est plus efficace si on
procède à la
télécférence forceadmettre que la
solution présentée est en adéquation
avec les
les exigences d'efficacité imposées au
administration
française le renfort technologique ne
veut que contribuer à une amélioration
du fonctionnement supposé archaïque de
l'administration pourtant il y a des
exemples de choses qui fonctionnent bien
aujourd'hui par exemple les permis de
les les cartes grises après quelques
problèmes ça fonctionne très très bien
et ça simplifie quand même les attentes
au au guichet des préfectures ou des
sous-préfectures qui étaient quand même
extraordinair il y a des choses qui
fonctionnent
les passeports c'est un peu encore
compliqué mais bon il y a quand même des
progrès il il m'est donc
paru il est inutile de rappeler que les
déliances formulées par nos concitoyens
Gard du dysfonctionnement de
l'administration abonde alors moi j'ai
quand même il y a toujours deux choses
qu'il faut faire auquel il faut faire
attention quand on utilise des procédés
électroniques il y a toujours la
sécurisation et la et la protection des
données je pense que ce sont des choses
qui sont extrêmement importantes sur
laquelle nous sommes des vigilants et et
comme on le sait c'est un débat mondial
euh donc nous sommes particulièrement la
commission des lois il faut que le
contrôle notamment de l'acnil soit
effectué avec rigueur les bienfaits
financier l'utilisation massive des
moyens électroniques et d'abandon
progressif des courriers papiers
pourtant devrait plaire à Madame Lipietz
hein quand même non ça devrait lui
plaire mais bon après apparemment rien
ne ne lui plaît dans ce projet
euh il me semble que le projet de loi ne
serurait suscité cvage
idéologique il m'est d'ailleurs agréable
de constater que ce type de mesure peut
faire l'objet d'un consensus où l'enjeu
d'efficacité prime il y a donc trois
axes le le le projet fixe d'abord la
simplification des relations entre le
public et les administrations avec la
création d'un code spécifique et
l'instauration d'un droit à saisir
l'administration par voie électronique
je dois avouer que
y a un petit problème c'est que il y a
quand même la fracture numérique dans
notre pays qui existe encore qui existe
encore même même en île-defance mais pas
évidemment dans la métropole peut-être
mais non elle existe donc et vous savez
je me suis rendu compte de ce phénomène
comme M on avait volé tous les câes
téléphoniques et bien je me suis rendu
compte qu'il y avait sur le nombre
d'abonnés de ma commune à peu près 150
il y en avait 25 qui n'avaient pas
internet qui n'avait pas internet donc
euh bah oui c'est quand même une
proportion nonnégligeable c'est bien
entendu soit des personnes âgées soit la
partie la plus faible de la
population alors je je pense quand même
que le il y a l'égalité devant la loi
que rappelle toujours le Conseil
constitutionnel
euh je vais pas vous citer toutes les
toutes les décisions mais l'instauration
d'un code visant à simplifier les
relations entre l'administration et ses
administrés offre un surplu de
visibilité aux citoyens désireux de
maîtriser le fonctionnement des
institutions alors ensuite vous et vous
avez insisté monsieur le rapporteur le
projet de loi tend à rénover le
processus décisionnel les dispositions
du projet introduisent la possibilité
d'accéder aux avis préalables et de
modifier en conséquence ça demande en
cours d'instruction alors en matière
d'urbanisme ça serait extrêmement utile
Madame le Ministre notamment vis-à-vis
des services départementaux
d'architecture d'abf parce qu' alors là
c'est c'est une administration qui ne
change pas et et on avait essayé
d'ailleurs de faire de renverser la vie
pr oui oui écoutez he c'est la
fantaisie quand ça change de
d'architecte il change de théorie et oui
mais nous le vivons monsieur le et là
alors comment non
mais mais moi aussi je je suis indulgent
mais à condition quand même qu'il y a un
dialogue certains ne n'acceptent pas le
dialogue hein bon en rupture avec la
règle traditionnelle de la
noncunicabilité des document
préparatoire une décision administrative
en cours
d'instruction posé par l'article 2 de la
loi du 17 juillet 78 notre texte
habiliterait le gouvernement à prendre
des dispositions législatives pour
prévoir qu'en principe sont
communicables l' demandeur les avis
rendus sur sa demande avant que ne soit
prise la décision je pense que c'est un
progrès en somme la rénovation du
processus décisionnel tant à renforcer
la participation du
public à l'élaboration des actes
administratifs à élargir la faculté de
recour à nouvelles technologie pour
délibérer ou rendre des avis à distance
et unifier les règles relatives au
régime des actes
administratifs enfin Madame le Ministre
et je suis d'accord sur ce qu'a dit
notre éminent collègue sur le sur les
codes qu'il faudrait rénover le code
électoral pose un petit problème c'est
que ça ne peut pas se faire à droit
constant vous le savez bien puisqueil y
a quand même et d'ailleurs nous avons
débattu longuement à la commission des
lois
pendant à plusieurs reprises sur le fait
que il y a quand même une petite
complication mais par contre c'est vrai
sur le code général des impôts c'est
vraiment c'est un monstre
incompréhensible incompréhensible sauf
par quelques spécialistes comme l'a dit
le comme l'a dit Alain Richard mais mais
en même temps on a l'impression
d'ailleurs que c'est quelques
spécialistes à ber qui ont leurs article
leur leurs chapitrees et et donc il
maîtrisent parfaitement on a
l'impression que si on leur enlevait ça
ils perdrai leur raison
d'être vous nous proposez la refondte du
code d'expropriation pour cause
d'utilité publique en ai parlé
euh et et bien
entendu voulez inclure dans le code les
dispositions de nature législativ qui n
pas été codifié améliorer le plan du
code et donner compéten en appel à la
juridiction de droit commun donc tous
ces toutes ces objectifs nous sommes
nous sommes bien entendu d'accord et
lors lors de sa conférence de presse du
16 mai 2013 le président de la
République a
évoqué Révolution il a pas dit un choc
un choc un choc le silence de
l'administration à l'expiration d'un
certain délai ne vaudrait plus rejet
mais autorisation cela reviendrait à
inverser le principe énoncé à l'article
21 de la loi 2321 du 12 avril 2000 sauf
dans les cas où un régime de décision
implicite de rejet sera institué dans
les conditions prévues par décret au
Conseil d'État le silence gardé pendant
plus de 2 mois par l'autorité
administrative sur une demande vaudrait
décision
d'acceptation madame le ministre si vous
y
arrivez parce que nous avons tenté à
plusieurs reprises et je ne veux citer
que les problèmes d'urbanisme et ben on
est vite revenu un petit peu à cause des
ABF mais vous voyez c'est je ne fais pas
une fixation hein je ne fais pas une
fixation mais
néanmoinsah si on prend pas la décision
alors tout le monde a peur dit il faut
mieux dire attendons tant que la
décision n'est pas prise je crois que ça
sera un progrès et
donc l'avenir
comment ah bah voilà ça y est vous voyez
immédiatement
réaction attendue attendu de ceux qui
ont une longue expérience de de la de
l'administration voilà l'avenir nous
Sira si cette déclaration très
empresscée du président de la République
trouve à se
réaliser complètement ou d'une manière
satisfaisante et donc après le travail
soigné du rapporteur et de la commission
des lois vre excellent collègue Portelli
le groupe
votera ce texte inscrit dans un
processus législatif
continu merci chers
collègues la discussion générale est
close et nous passons à la discussion du
texte de la commission article
additionnel avant l'article 1er
amendement numéro 3 il est présenté par
Madame le Ministre au nom du
gouvernement
oui en remerciant la qualité du travail
exposé par le rapporteur et et juste en
faisant en amont quelques
remarques en particulier pu puisque j'ai
j'ai ramassé les intervention le
gouvernement demandera au SGG monsieur
Richard d'organiser un rendez-vous avec
la commission des lois au cours du
travail sur les ordonnances afin de ne
pas présenter au Parlement des
ordonnances achevées c'est donc un un
engagement de la même manière que sur le
champ du code relatif aux relations
entre l'administration et les usagers le
gouvernement demande l'habilitation à
codifier sur le champ de la loi cada
parmi entre guillemets les grandes lois
à codifier toutes n'ont pas le même
champ d'où l'obligation de retenir pour
nous le champ le plus large
naturellement et beaucoup se sont
inquiétés sur le numérique le numérique
devient un une possibilité pas pas une
obligation monsieur fav d'autres ensuite
he presque tous les les trois derniers
intervenants y ont fait allusion donc
pour nous c'est vraiment un moyen
supplémentaire et il faut faire
attention vous avez raison à ce que ce
ne soit pas une obligation sinon on
ferait on créerait une rupture du droit
donc bien évidemment ce ne sera pas le
cas j'ai entendu les
inquiétudes sur les accords tacit
j'assume je dis bien j'assume une
proposition fait au président de la
République
euh qu' l' accepté avec enthousiasme et
qui a décrite avec autant d'enthousiasme
euh pourquoi je vous demande d'accepter
l'amendement numéro 3 qui est un article
additionnel avant l'article 1er de ce
projet de loi pour modifier comme je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure la loi 2321 du
12 avril 2000 dont j'apprécie d'ailleurs
si ou là on on reconnaisse le bien fondé
et donc je vous demande de prévoir que
le principe selon lequel le silence
gardé pendant 2 mois sur une demande
vaut acceptation les domaines dans
lesquels ce principe ne peut être
appliqué le silence vaudra alors rejet
la possibilité d'écarter ce principe par
décret en Conseil d'État et en conseil
des ministres et la possibilité de faire
varier le délai de 2 mois par décret en
Conseil d'État je vais revenir une
publication sur un site internet des
procédures pour lesquelles le silence
vaut acceptation et le délai
d'intervention de la décision tacite
enfin le début non pas enfin encore deux
mesures le début du délai à la table de
réception du dossier complet par
l'administration compétente et enfin des
mesures de publicité à l'gard des tiers
et la possibilité pour le demandeur
d'obtenir une attestation de
l'administration c'est vrai que
d'cin nous souhaite bon courage à la
limite bonne chance pour pour y arriver
on y a mis comme vous l'avez tous à
travers vos propos demander un certain N
nombre de barrières parce
qu'effectivement sur des dossiers qui
concernent la santé par exemple des
protections de de l'environnement de
nouvelles applications de directiv
européenne qui interviendrait
effectivement il faudrait avoir un délai
plus long chacun en convient euh moi je
attachais beaucoup d'importance à ce
qu'on détermine de façon le plus exacte
possible le moment à partir duquel le
délai démarre euh pour éviter que
connaissant et pratiquant bien le droit
les uns euh pose un dossier incomplet je
ne veux pas dire volontairement
incomplet je peux dire accidentellement
incomplet et que le délai démarre à
cette dateelà non le délai démarre au
dossier complet et il faudra qu'on
regarde bien ensemble donc au décès
complet je le dis au banc volontairement
il faudra qu'on regarde bien au moment
de l'écriture et naturellement vous je
sais que vous y serez attentif le fait
que une
administration peut émettre non pas un
avis mais faire des remarques sur le
dossier et que ça fasse redémarrer le
délai alors je ne veux pas dire qu'on va
avoir ce que chacun imagine possible
toutes les semaines une remarque d'un
tel ou d'un tel un tel la BF don souvent
je ne comprends pas pourquoi d'ailleurs
la BF a été aussi souvent cité faisant
une remarque et faisant repartir le
délai jusqu'à ce que ça dure un ou de
ans non donc au maximum du droit de la
protection des citoyens et de la
protection de la terre j'ai envie de
dire au maximum les 2 mois à partir du
dossier complet euh le silence de 2 mois
vaudra acceptation je pense que cet
engagement oblige les administrations
j'ai pas bien compris l'argument de
Madame lipiet parce que dans le même
temps euh nous avons préparé une loi sur
notre sur nos fonctionnaires sur le
statut de nos fonctionnaires sur leur
impartialité mais aussi sur tous les
codes qui correspondent à la
transparence et cetera moi je leur fais
confiance et je leur fais confiance pour
y compris entendre ce qu'on leur demande
par cet amendement donc le gouvernement
a plaisir à vous poser cet amendement et
espère être
suivi madame la ministre on était sur
l'amendement oui donc très
bien sur le tout très bien monsieur le
rapporteur quel est l'avis de la
commission sur cette amendement numéro 3
la commission a donné un avis favorable
merci Monsieur rapporteur pas de demande
merci Madame lip madame lipi pour
explication de vote
oui merci monsieur le
Président j'ai donc déjà expliqué le
problème que la procédure d'entrisme de
cet amendement me pose on modifie par un
amendement de deux pages enfin une page
3/4 une loi pour ensuite être autorisé à
codifier son propre texte mais sur le
fond et dans les 3 minutes qui me sont
impartis je fais remarquer d'abord que
dire que le silence ou acceptation dans
certains cas ne sert quasiment à rien si
on ne clarifie pas le délai de retrait
de cette
décision tacite et ça ça va être un
véritable
casse-tête connu et que je vous souhaite
effectivement bien du plaisir à résoudre
on l'a toutefois fait je fa remarquer en
matière d'urbanisme sur le délai
glissant que vous avez prévu si
l'administration a demandé des documents
euh je suis j'ai peut-être été trop
avocate pendant trop longtemps de
administré qui se font renvoyer de délai
en délai l'administration n'ayant jamais
assez de documents même lorsque le
silence de l'administration vut rejet
par exemple au bout de 4 mois et je
pense aux étrangers j'arrive presque à
mes 4 mois pour pouvoir j'arrivais
presque aux 4 mois pour pouvoir faire
une demande devant le tribunal contre
une décision de rejet et à ce moment là
on me demandait une pièce supplémentaire
et ça continuait et ça continuait voilà
pourquoi je suis extrême mauvaise langue
mais ce qui me pose le plus de problème
c'est l'article 21 qui comporte
tellement de dérogation renversement du
principe qu'on ne voit pas très bien en
pratique le résultat final je crains
aussi que la liste et malgré les
dérogations du Grand 2 qui devrait être
pris par décets permet à des sociétés
d'obtenir des autorisations implicites
dangereuses ou nuisibles parfois alors
même que le dossier aura été baclé
malgré les gardes fous on a déjà plus de
permis de construire illégaux tacit
qu'explicite
pour ma part je l'miterai cette
acceptation tacite et encore aux
demandes des personnes physiques le
grand 2 est une aberération puisque si
le principe est que les accords sont
tacites on ne voit pas on ne doit pas
pardon faire une liste de tel cas au
risque d'en oubli mais bien une liste
des cas inverses où le silence vos refus
l'article 22 est bon s un principe
encore qu'il faudrait étendre les
hypothèses des mesures de publicité pour
les tiers qui n'existent guerre en
dehors de de urbanisme et de la fonction
publique même lorsque ces décisions
tacit Express auront été publiés sur un
site internet comme certains orateurs
l'ont fait remarquer il y a toujours le
problème de la fracture numérique reste
aussi et j'ai déjà dit mais je le répète
en général le retrait des actes tacides
bref les problèmes posés par ces
amendement mérite par cet amendement
pardon mériterait plus d'étude et si
pourquoi si le principe est peut-être
bon il ne peut être voté ainsi à la va
vite même si j'ai bien entendu madame la
ministre que nous aurons le plaisir de
discuter avec le gouvernement en cours
d'élaboration
euh cette principe de voter ainsi un tel
amendement à la vavite paraît un petit
peu choquant par rapport au travail qui
est en train de faire un rapport
d'évaluation qui est en cours auprès de
la CADAC et on aurait pu attendre un
petit peu pour voir jusqu'où aller euh
c'est pourquoi compte tenu de mes
réticences vis-à-vis de ce texte le
groupe écologie s'abstiendra quant à cet
amendement merci chers collègues madame
la ministre vous avez la parole moi je
vais pas reprendre tous les arguments en
revanche vous avez au départ parlé de
délai de retrait vous avez dans
l'article 23 de la loi 2000 dont on a
parlé tout à
l'heure des des trois points pendant
lesquels il peut y avoir des l de
retrait donc c'est déjà écrit dans dans
le droit dans notre droit
merci Madame la Ministre 23 je n'ai pas
d'autre demande d'explication de vote
que ceux qui souhaitent adopter cet
amendement ve bien lever la
main merci opposition ce qui son
abstention merci beaucoup il est adopté
amendement sur l'article 1er
l'amendement premier rectifié est
présenté par Madame
lipiz merci monsieur le Président on a
parlé de de la publication
des des des décisions par internet ou
même plutôt les les discussions par
internet que l'on pourra avoir entre
administration et et citoyens euh bien
sûr que les écologistes sont tout à fait
pour et pas simplement parce que ça fait
économiser du papier comme souvent on le
présente mais aussi parce que en général
c'est moins énergivore donc c'est
vraiment quelque chose de très bien
toutefois le numérique n'est pas
simplement internet mais c'est-à-dire
les adresses les les liens les contacts
que l'on peut avoir mais c'est aussi la
toile et c'est-à-dire l'ensemble des
des des des éléments que l'on peut avoir
à sa disposition et que l'on peut
reprendre à sa charge et en faire des
articles et c'est
pourquoi je propose cet amendement
d'appel parce que je sais que je n'ai
pas le droit de le faire mais c'est pas
grave je le fais quand même à savoir la
définition des conditions dans
lesquelles seront publiées les
délibérations de telle façon à que ù
tous les avis de l'administration de
telle façon à ce que
cette ces avis ou ces décisions de
l'administration reçoivent une large
publicité au sens public c'est-à-dire
que chacun puisse les faire sien et
notamment en les réutilisant et en
refaisant des recherches sur internet
c'est l'Open Data que je voudrais
réellement mettre à disposition de tous
les citoyens l'utilisation d'un cyle
public d'ouverture des données est en un
gage de
pérenité des décisions administratives
merci porteur quel est l'avis de la
commission avis défavorable d'ailleurs
madame lip vient de le dire les
parlementaires n'ont pas le droit de
d'avoir l'initiative en matière
d'ordonnance réservé au gouvernement
merci Madame la Ministre quel est l'avis
du
Gouvernement je j'admire le le
rapporteur parce que l'avis du
Gouvernement est un avis de de sagesse
pourquoi c'est vrai que sur le les
éléments qui viennent d'être doné
l'ouverture des données publiques de
l'État et des opérateurs a fait l'objet
de plusieurs décisions dans le cadre de
la map et des travaux sont en cours
entre étalab et les collectivité locales
regroupé au sein d'Open Data France pour
avancer dans une direction commune le
projet de loi de développement des
solidarités territoriale et de la
démocratie locale déposé sur le bureau
du Sénat propose des avancées
supplémentaires donc dans ce que là il
me semble possible d'accepter
l'amendement merci madame la
ministre
je réponds à à à Bab bruit au au
rapporteur dans la mesure où il estime
qu'effectivement je fais une erreur et
qu'il est anticonstitutionnel je vais
demander à Madame lipiè de retirer son
amendement et moi je vais faire regarder
de plus près une explication que nous
avons travaillé en amont et qui ne
semble pas convenir donc merci monsieur
le rapporteur merci Madame la Ministre
madame IP s-il retiré mais je pense que
le gouvernement pourrait le reprendre à
son compte et dans ce cas-là ça serait
son amendement non c'est pas possible
ah ben non si c'est son amendement il
est il est anticonstitutionnel parce que
c'est moi qui l'ai déposé mais si c'est
le gouvernement qui nous propose de le
gouver de le de l'adopter je ne sais pas
don j'en déduis que vous ne le retirez
pas si il est retiré il est retiré nous
votons sur l'article 1er pas de demande
d'explication oui pardon madame la
ministre ne vais pas reprendre un
amendement comme ça au piedlevé si vous
permettez cette expression monsieur le
Président donc en revanche je m'engage à
le reprendre devant les députés
merci de cette précision madame la
ministre nous votons donc sur l'article
1er pas de demande d'explication de vote
que ceux qui souhaitent l'adopter veille
bien lever la main unanimité je vous
remercie amendement sur l'article 2
l'amendement 4 madame la ministre est
défendu défendu monsieur le rapporteur
quel est l'avis du de la commission avis
favorable favorable pas de demande
d'explication de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent l'adopter veille bien lever
la main
merci unanimité il est adopté
l'amendement numéro 5 est défendu
monsieur le rapporteur l'avis de la
commission favorable favorable pas de
demande d'explication de vote même vote
même vote l'amendement numéro 6 est
défendu même avis monsieur le rapporteur
non monsieur rapporteur avis de la
commission est défavorable monsieur le
Président pour une raison très simple
c'est que habituellement c'est le terme
de signature qui qui qui n'est c'est
plutôt le terme de appliation est
utilisé or l'argument qui nous a été
avancé par le gouvernement c'est qu'il
pouvait y avoir un délai de quelques
jours entre le moment où le texte est
signé le moment où il est publié nous
faisons remarquer au gouvernement que
c'est les mêmes autorités qui publient
et qui signent donc c'est à elle de
s'organiser pour éviter ce genre de
désagrément merci monsieur le rapporteur
de cette précision madame la ministre
vous vouliez
intervenir il y a un petit
désaccord entre nous puisqueen l'état la
rédaction retenue prévoit codification
des règles en vigueur à la date de la
publication de l'ordonnance toutefois en
pratique des règles qui entreront en
vigueur postérieurement à la signature
de l'ordonnance et préalablement à sa
publication ne pourront pas être codifié
puisque l'ordonnance ne pourra pas être
complétée après signature cet amendement
réétablit donc la rédaction du projet de
loi qui prévoyait de figer l'état des
règles à codifieré à la date de la
signature de
l'ordonnance oui monsieur Richard pour
explication de
vote
une querelle qui ne peut être comprise
que par quelques dizaines de personnes
en France et qui de surcroix n'a aucun
intérêt de quoi
s'agit-il quand on est en train de
codifier un texte on collecte tout un
ensemble de textes qu'on considère
devoir entrer dans le dans le contenu de
ce code
alors simplement tant que le texte de
codification n'est pas entré en vigueur
tous ces textes continuent à bouger
puisque naturellement la France ne peut
pas se passer de quelques dizaines de
changements de règles de droit par jour
et donc le sujet c'est que une fois que
les codificateurs ont fini leur travail
que tout ça a été
euh complètement figé par le SGG en fin
de parcours le temps qu'on collecte les
signatures et que survienne le délai de
sortie au au JO qui en général prend
quelques jours parce que c'est des
textes lourds il peut y avoir un des
textes qui viennent d'être codif qui
viennent d'être codifié qui est modifié
je pense que la seule solution c'est que
le SG qui a tous les talents retarde la
publication du dernier texte modifié
pour que ça soit une première
modification du nouveau Code plutôt que
de jouer sur une date de signature qui
quand il y a quatre ou C contre
signataires est à peu près impossible à
prouver merci chers collègues monsieur
le rapporteur vous avez la parole juste
un mot pour dire que en pratique ce
qu'on vient de dire depuis début de la
discussion de ce texte c'est qu'on met
des années pour sortir un code et là on
se bagarre pour des jours c'est dire que
le SGG serait incapable de gérer
quelques jours alors qu'il met des
années pour faire sortir un
code merci monsieur le rapporteur je
n'ai pas d'autre demande d'explication
de vote que ceux qui souhaitent adopter
cet amendement ve bien lever la
main merci que ceux qui sont contre
veulent bien lever la main l'amendement
n'est pas adopté deux amendements font
l'objet d'une discussion commune
l'amendement numéro 7 il est soutenu
madame la ministre oui et l'amendement
numéro 9 est présenté par monsieur le
rapporteur
oui monsieur le Président en fait le
problème c'est que dans le texte qui a
été adopté par la commission donc il
s'agissait de viser les retraits des
actes administratifs
et donc le administratifs unilatéraux le
gouvernement dans ses explications dans
la discussion que nous avons eu avec lui
nous a expliqué qu'en fait il s'agissait
pas simplement du retrait mais également
de l'abrogation donc pour faire un pas
en direction du gouvernement nous avons
proposé donc dans l'amendement numéro 9
d'ajouter après le mot retrait donc le
retrait et l'abrogation mais de
maintenir le texte de la commission donc
je pense que de la sorte les intentions
du gouvernement sont satisfaites et les
préventions de la commission également
car nous n'avons pas du tout envie de
voir ajouter d'autres dispositifs que ce
relatif faut retrait à l'abrogation dans
le texte de l'habilitation et donc vous
demandez en réalité le retrait de
l'amendement numéro
7 voilà bonjour madame la ministre alors
trè très immédiatement est-ce que le
gouvernement accepte de retirer le
numéro 7 et quel est son avis sur
l'amendement numéro 9 et bien la l'avis
du Gouvernement monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
messieurs les rapporteurs c'est de
d'accepter de retirer l'amendement
numéro 7 et de donner un avis favorable
sur le 9 merci Madame la Ministre pas de
demande d'explication de vote que ceux
qui souhaitent adopter cet amendement
numéro 9 veuille bien lever la
main unanimité je vous
remercie nous en arrivons à l'amendement
numéro 2 il est présenté par Madame
lipiatz encore une entorse peut-être
puisqu'il s'agit d'un appel d'un
amendement d'appel
c'est la loi 2002 276 du 27 février 2002
relative à démocratie de proximité entre
guillemets qui a supprimé la seule règle
de fond tirant une conséquence de l'avis
défavorable d'une enquête à une enquête
publique avant cette loi il fallait
systématiquement un décret en Conseil
d'État si la vie n'avait pas été
favorable c'est d'ailleurs toujours
exigé pour certaines opérations énorme
mais le sens de l'enquête est dans ces
cas indifférent il y a 11 ans on avait
sans doute considéré qu'exiger un décret
en Conseil d'État lorsque des élus
responsables avaient opiné en faveur de
l'utilité publ de leur projet fuss-il
démesuré était une forme de méfiance
envers les élus locaux c'est pourquoi la
démocratie locale où l'idée que l'on se
faisait alors a était parfois avait pris
cette loi en régression par rapport à la
démocratie réelle locale qui se base sur
la con consulttion des citoyens
aujourd'hui la un avis défavorable à la
suite d'une consultation une une
commission d'enquête n'a absolument
aucune conséquence juridique sauf la
présomption d'urgence en cas de référé
suspension je vous laisse les l'article
du code de
l'environnement à noter que non
seulement un avis défavorable n'a aucune
conséquence mais qu'il y a une certaine
tendance des préfets en cas d'avis avec
réserve RP défavorable si le projet
n'est pas modifié dans le sens des
réserves à ne pas tenir compte des
réserves par qu car requérant
soutiennent qu'il faudrait refaire une
autre enquête et ça c'est d'ailleurs vu
ce qui est vrai quand les modifications
ne sont pas la conséquence directe de la
vie à noter qu'il s'agit d'une rgle
prétorienne et que son écriture dispense
de nouvell et que son écriture pardon
dispense de nouvelles enquête si le
projet est modifié au seul fin de
répondre aux réserves serait une
amélioration bref c'est l'unit ité pour
les citoyens d'aller faire savoir leur
accord ou désaccord lors de l'enquête
que qui explique pourquoi peu de
personnes se déplace à ce genre
d'enquête donner un sens à l'avis
négatif est le souhait des écologistes
qui devrait être entendu aujourd'hui ou
demain par le
gouvernement merci chers collègues
monsieur le rapporteur quel est l'avis
de la commission l'avis est des
favorable ou ou sinon retrait pour une
raison très simple c'est que le droit en
vigueur prévoit déjà quand même un som
de choses notamment le droit de
l'environnement le code prévoit que en
cas d'avis négatif de enfin de de
conclusion négative du commissaire
enquêteur et bien il faut que la
collectivité émette une délibération
motivée pour demander la suite de la
procédure merci monsieur le rapporteur
madame la ministre quel est l'avis du
Gouvernement monsieur le Président
Madame la sénateur je ne peux pas donner
meilleur avis que celui proposé par
Monsieur Portelli et donc c'est à mon
tour de dire rejet ou défavorable merci
est-il retiré madame non il n'est pas
retiré pas de demande d'explication de
vote que ceux qui sohaitent adopté veut
bien lever la main merci et que ceux qui
sont contre veut bien lever la main
l'amendement n'est pas adopté nous
votons sur l'article 2 pas de demande
d'explication de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent l' adopter veutent bien lever
la main merci opposition il est adopté
amendement sur l'article 3 l'amendement
8 il est défendu madame la ministre ou
il est
défendu monsieur le rapporteur quel est
l'avis de la commission
la vie est défavorable pour la même
raison que tout à
l'heure
merci madame la ministre monsieur le
Président j'entends bien que
effectivement cet amendement a été
défendu j'entends bien que on a eu un
avis défavorable je voudrais quand même
pour ma part insister sur le principe de
vacuité parce qu'on est sur un principe
de vacuité entre deux temps entre le
temps où on signe et le temps où il y a
publication et bien il peut y arriver
effectivement qu'on ait des décisions à
prendre et là il y a vacuité et je
reviens sur le mot vacuité c'est c'est
pas le vide c'est que on est vraiment
dans ce qui n'existe pas et c'est pour
ça que le gouvernement avait présenté
cet amendement que je veux représenter
quand même défendre avec vigueur et
détermination merci madame la ministre
je passe la parole à Monsieur le
rapporteur merci monsieur le Président
il y a aucune vacuité pour une raison
très simple c'est que on parle de
codification on est en train de parler
de codification de texte on ne codifie
pas des décisions et donc il y a pas de
vacuité il s'agit de de de de textes qui
peuvent être dans le pire des cas des
circulaires ou des directives et donc ce
sont des des documents administratifs
des actes administratifs qu'on est
capable de planifier unant soit peu et
qu'on est dont on peut remettre la
publication de façon euh rationnelle
puisque ce sont toujours les mêmes
autorités qui se trouvent décisionnaire
de ce processus qu'il soit qu'il se
termine momentanément par une signature
ou qu'il se termine par une publication
merci monsieur le rapporteur alors nous
allons voter sur cet amendement je n'ai
pas de demande d'explication de vote que
ceux qui souhaitent adopter veuillent
bien lever la
main que ceux qui sont contre veuillent
bien lever la main unanimité il n'est
pas adopté nous votons sur l'article 3
pas de demande d'explication de vote que
ceux qui souhaitent l'adopter veent bien
lever la main
merci que ceux qui sont contre veent
bien lever la main il est adopté je vais
mettre au voix l'ensemble du projet de
loi il y a-t-il des demandes
d'explication de vote s'il a pas je mets
au voix donc l'ensemble du projet
habilitant le gouvernement à simplifier
les relations entre l'administration et
les citoyens que ceux qui souhaitent
l'adopter veuille bien lever la
main merci je ne vois pas d'opposition
il est donc pas d'abstention il est est
adopté à l'unanimité et je vous remercie
voilà pour cette séance consacrée à la
simplification des relations entre
l'administration et les citoyens
prochain rendez-vous avec les travaux
parlementaires c'est cet après-midi à
partir de 16h30 avec l'examen séance
publique du projet de loi relatif à la
lutte contre la fraudte fiscale bonne
journée à
tous